Jean-Louis devrait le ministre de
l'intérieur était lui aujourd'hui dans
la région de Tours où il s'est félicité
de la politique qu'il a mené menée par
le gouvernement en matière d'immigration
reportage j'habite un verre Franz
vaillant chez les candidats de droite on
se la rate pas moins de 50 demandes sur
son bureau Jean-Louis Debré c'est
l'homme le plus demandé du gouvernement
pour venir épauler les campagnes
électorales aujourd'hui c'est à cinq
candidats dont son propre frère Bernard
que le ministre est venu prêter main
forte
la loi qui porte son nom a fait sa
réputation Jean-Louis Debré est celui
qui montre les muscles du gouvernement
sur la sécurité ou l'immigration
clandestine
et lorsqu'il s'installent et qui se
mettent à ouvrir votre frigidaire est-ce
que vous l'avez pas qu'une envie c'est
qu'il s'en aille un couteau Philippe
Jean-Louis devrait considère qu'une
campagne électorale c'est d'abord
beaucoup de dégustations et pas mal
d'effusions parfois il arrive de tomber
sur un électeur mécontent de payer trop
d'impôts par exemple
du premier tour un autre débat un grand
débat est en train de surgir au sein de
la majorité concernant la Juppé de ce
que nous avons entendu recueilli comme
témoignage et bien il faudra une
nouvelle équipe
un nouveau Premier ministre et c'est au
président de la République de choisir ce
nouveau Premier ministre Alain Juppé
restera-t-il ou non à Matignon si la
droite remporte les élections ce sont
ses propres partisans qui posent
aujourd'hui la question de l'avenir du
Premier ministre cela fait peut-être
partie d'une tactique électorale avant
même de connaître les projets politiques
en tout cas c'est bien l'avenir des
hommes qui domine ce début de campagne
c'est les candidats de droite on se
l'arrache pas moins de 50 demandes sur
son bureau Jean-Louis Debré c'est
l'homme le plus demandé du gouvernement
pour venir épauler les campagnes
électorales aujourd'hui c'est à 5
candidats dont son propre frère Bernard
que le ministre est venu prêter main
fort
la loi qui porte son nom à fait sa
réputation Jean-Louis Debré est celui
qui montre les muscles du gouvernement
sur la sécurité ou l'immigration
clandestine
et lorsqu'il s'installent et qui se
mettent à ouvrir votre frigidaire est-ce
que vous l'avez pas
considère qu'une campagne électorale
c'est d'abord beaucoup de dégustations
et pas mal d'excusions parfois il arrive
de tomber sur un électeur mécontent de
payer trop d'impôts par exemple
à moins de 4 semaines du premier tour un
autre débat un grand débat est en train
de surgir au sein de la majorité il
concerne la jumper de ce que nous avons
entendu recueilli comme témoignage et
bien il faudra une nouvelle équipe un
nouveau Premier ministre et c'est au
président de la République de choisir ce
nouveau Premier ministre Alain Juppé
restera-t-il ou non à Matignon si la
droite remporte les élections ce sont
ses propres partisans qui posent
aujourd'hui la question de l'avenir du
Premier ministre cela fait peut-être
partie d'une tactique électorale avant
même de connaître les projets politiques
en tout cas c'est bien l'avenir des
hommes qui domine ce début de campagne